he is a part of the pro football talk
world with mike florio
every single day that launches our day
on nbc sports on peacock
and he's also the host of the chris sims
unbuttoned podcast chris sims how you
been chris
i'm doing good rich man how are you man
it has it's been a long time i don't
think i've seen you since
um super bowl 50 right that when we were
out there in san francisco so
it's good to catch up with you man i
hope you're well well and and uh you
know i i i don't
i didn't mean for it to be once every
five years but uh let's
let's have a good chat right here um so
let's let's get right into it i'll give
you the floor
i i uh was traveling to work today when
you were on with florio so
what what is what is your take on dac
being signed to
uh this uh very lucrative contract chris
sims
right i think the first thing i mean wow
about the money right i mean just you
know
that that popped off to me right away
four years get 160 million dollars but i
think like my base
thought more than anything is i mean the
cowboys
had no choice here you don't let what i
look at is
a top 10 quarterback like definitive top
10 quarterback in the nfl
fringe top five-ish type quarterback
walk out the door
not only because of the talent and the
things he has
but also the intangibles he brings so he
brings tangibles on the field
that he probably doesn't get enough
credit for because it's not quite as
sexy as mahomes or
rogers or russell wilson and it doesn't
have that flair
but the results are really damn good and
the leadership what he brings to the
locker room being the face of the
franchise he has all of that that goes
with it
let alone rich i'll say this too i mean
you know i mean the cowboys are
it didn't look good last year and i
think today i mean their defense of
course is going to be
you know a major work in progress this
offseason the running game is not what
it was
two three years ago zeke's not the same
back that offensive line's not as
dominant
the team right now their bright spot is
their receivers their passing game
and we saw without an elite quarterback
in there last year
you know they they weren't nearly as fun
to watch explosive at an offense or
anything like that so
you know with dak prescott definite top
10 quarterback glad to see him get paid
like that
and i think that jerry jones just
realized i can't let this guy go right
now
no chance and not a way that not the way
the team is set up currently here going
into the 2021 season i agree with you
chris
i'm not going to get caught up in that
whole business of is dak worth it he is
worth it because he did what he has done
and right and and it is his time he has
the leverage
he has the ability and that's
what the market bears certainly if the
cowboys had play
you know played it the way that they
played it over the last couple of years
so i'm i'm not going to get caught up in
all of that
but now it is time it is now time to win
though in the
in in this four years he's got to do
that he's got to win it all i mean if
they come away with no
libardi trophies through these four
years then it is not a success
um and there's different shades of
success but not
at the ultimate success so how do they
do that do they have the right
coach do you think moving forward how
does mccarthy now
because we did see the first four weeks
of of him with mccarthy but
that's kind of an outlier because they
were down 50 to nothing in the at
halftime of pretty much every single one
of those games so what do you think
no doubt and then i mean he had some you
know game management issues early on
listen
mike mccarthy i think he's a real good
head coach i always
questioned his offensive game planning a
little bit with green bay and aaron
rodgers
but the good thing that he's done here
since since he's been in dallas
you know it's a collaborative effort
with him and kellen moore so i like that
aspect
but they're gonna you know you're you're
right with everything you said
i mean hey the pressure's on that
prescott now there's no doubt about that
you know when you sign this type of deal
and if you start off one and four or
don't get to the playoffs
you know three to four years here it's
all you're going to hear if you're him
is oh well you took all the money
there's not enough money to
to make a complete team around you and
and all those issues
so that pressure is there it's going to
be on him especially because of the
things we've talked about too
the strength of their team are those
wide receivers and him throwing the
football so they're going to have to
carry it
you can put those weapons up there as
far as that wide receiver
up with just about anybody in football
it's that talented across the board
now i like that they got dan quinn in
there you know that was the biggest
issue that last year
they got a coach in there that really
coached 3-4 style of football
and they had 4-3 style defensive
football players
so the players in the scheme did not
mesh so they have a lot of work to do
there's no doubt
the good thing is they don't have a huge
salary cap number
this year for dak we don't know exactly
where the salary caps gonna be
right but when i look at the cowboys
more than anything rich it is about the
defense
i mean there's really the front demarcus
lawrence has been a little underwhelming
for what he's paid there's no doubt
about that they got to get some
disruptors and difference makers on
their front four
they're going to play that seattle
scheme defense they don't have a cam
chancellor or
earl thomas type of guy in the back end
there so
they got a lot of issues on the
defensive side of the ball hopefully now
with dak signed up they don't have to
worry about the offense and they can fix
that chris sims here
pro football talk live pft live uh
co-host and also the
host of chris sims unbuttoned podcasts
where all podcasts are gotten
all right let's get into it how uh i
mean uh uh
how much of the name zack wilson have
you heard on uh social media and on your
phone
in the last week well chris i mean i you
know not as much as you're an idiot
you're stupid
you only have this job because your dad
all those i mean you know
so i i i've been criticized the first
and
it's it's it's same old same old it's
like rinse cycle repeat for me with this
conversation i took the same crap last
year when i said
herbert was better than tua you know i
um
so zach wilson again just i think what
everybody takes away from it more than
anything is they think it's an
indictment on trevor lawrence
and it's not trevor lawrence is awesome
i love it he's worthy of being the
number one pick
it's the last thing i wrote on my
sentence this guy's a baller
he's definitely worthy of the number one
pick i wrote that in my notes
only thing is as i think just zack
wilson's better i i think zach wilson
has mahomes and rogers-ish type
qualities about his game first off he's
a more
he's a more consistent thrower to me
rich than trevor lawrence and i just
mean
with there's a 10 yard out a 15 yard
comeback a 20 yard in cut
he will consistently hit the bullseye
more than lawrence
but i think what takes it to the other
level for me is
when there is nothing there and
everybody is covered at byu
he does have that magician-like quality
like the mahomes or rogers to buy
time and then throw a 30-yard laser you
know all over the field whether he's
jumping in the air throwing across his
body
you know can't move in the pocket so i
knew zach wilson was talented i'm a
casual college football watcher on
saturdays
but i was blown away with what i saw in
film i didn't go into it going
oh i'm going to shake up the draft world
and put him number one over trevor
lawrence
i had burrow won last year i had kyler
murray won the year before that
this is one that just really jumped out
to me and i'm excited about what i saw
from zack wilson so let's
let's dig into this a little bit more
focusing on
on trevor lawrence do you think that
there
um you know is going to be a
conversation
in jacksonville similar to what you have
unpacked here because you know because
you know
you know how this process works every
single snap
is going to be ground down to the right
to something that you can't even see
anymore even you know
uh the the story that jim morris senior
told me is that they grinded tape on
peyton manning and ryan leaf literally
to the last minute
you know so that's the way these things
go despite the hindsight
uh but we also know you know we also
know urban didn't just take a bite at
the nfl apple just because
you know so so what do you think is
going to be the conversation in
jacksonville on this very subject when
it comes down to it
chris i i mean i think there could be
some conversation but i think
you said it right there's too many signs
that point towards it's going to be
trevor lawrence there hey one let's just
take him from the business aspect
he's a huge draw in that part of the
country he grew up in georgia he played
there at south carolina clemson
you know this is sec country and he's
been in a lot of big time college
football games and played awesome in
them
so from that standpoint it makes sense
you said it the urban meyer thing he
took that job thinking hey i'm gonna get
trevor lawrence at number one
you know i'm sure they've looked at it
and gone man zach wills i mean i don't
know how you can't look at zach wilson
and go whoa holy crap look at that throw
look at this play
but but i also this is where i go i
expected to beat trevor lawrence with
the number one pick
because of the offense they're going to
run i know daryl bevels the offensive
coordinator there
but i think you're going to still see a
lot of urban meyer
ecology stuff in that offense and i do
think trevor lawrence
is is built for that with the ability to
you know
run the read option the rpos all that a
lot of screens
oh let's fake the screen let's throw a
30-yard ball down the right sideline
you know let's fake the slant throw the
ball deep down the sideline that way
he's got a powerful arm he can make
every throw he's a great back shoulder
thrower and there's a lot of throws
outside the numbers
and size is a skill his ability like a
justin herbert last year
you know when there's people around him
in the pocket he's so big he can throw
right over the top of them there there's
something to that
you know brady can do that mahomes can't
you know so those are things i do look
at i
expect him to be number one because of
all those reasons i really do
but i also think that when i say that i
think zack wilson probably
fits into more systems and is more
nfl drop back pass game ready
than trevor lawrence's at this point of
his career let alone
i think zach wilson's talents a little
bit better too chris sims here on the
rich eisen show and you know
uh i guess you were 10 or 11 when uh
when your dad was attempting to win a
second super bowl and then
got hurt and um so you you had a front
row seat to
to know about what a crucible it is to
be a a new york city quarterback and
then here comes zach wilson
now sitting there for the jets so i
guess it's more of a germain
conversation to ask you with all your
perspective
um what the conversation is in the jets
building rather than the jaguars
building
so right with darnold there and the
second overall pick and then who the
heck knows when the texans might
you know smell whatever coffee that
desean watson is telling them to smell
uh what do you think the the
conversation is here with robert sala
bringing in
uh the shanahan system what do you think
about all this yeah it's i mean they're
they're they're sitting pretty
is what i do think more than anything
they got a lot of options
you know the first thing let's hit the
desean watson part
to me that makes no sense from the from
the jets standpoint listen i
i love deshaun watson he's one of the
five best quarterbacks in football
but what are the jets going to do take
to sean watson trade away
all their draft picks and assets so they
can be four and 12 with desean watson
sean watson just like the houston texas
you know that to me
is where the jets have a major rebuild
in front of them right now so that to me
does not make sense
sam darnold i don't i'm not giving up on
sam darnold
i i was one a month ago before i started
studying these quarterbacks i went i got
no issue if the jets stay with him
he'll fit that shanahan michael lafleur
system that you're talking about
and again i've seen enough good from him
to still
think you can go to a playoff and get to
a super bowl with sam darnold
you know like i always said to mike
florio when you're surrounded by crap
and you got crap all around you
hey you're gonna smell like crap and get
some crap on you too i mean it's just
hard to look good with the support
system he's had around
him but i think my ultimate thought is
this rich
yes i just look at it and i go how could
robert
sala and mike lafleur not be looking at
zach wilson
and mike lafleur not be looking at his
brother and matt lafleur and going wait
i'm gonna run
that same system in green bay and that
guy up there just had 48 touchdown
passes and five interceptions
and they don't lose games in the regular
season and that to me is where zach
wilson is the perfect fit
for that shanahan system play action
aggressive passes
all the movement the bootlegs he is an
amazing thrower on the run
i mean it's mahomes and rogers-ish when
it comes to that
so when i look at it i just go man that
just makes too much sense to me
and with all those draft picks you got a
chance to really build
something and build a nucleus that can
come up the ranks and excite the fans
here in new york
about the jets and that that's what at
least that's what my my uh
my move would be rich yeah i was
chopping it up yesterday with peter king
another
one of our colleagues here on nbc sports
chris yesterday
and that maybe the jets could move out
of the two
right uh right and you know let's just
say
i just threw out the eagles for instance
because you know
they have a history of moving up to
number two to take a quarterback but
they did it
you know they they hopped a couple of
times they made a trade with miami to
then
eventually leap up to go get wence at
number two
they're already at the ninth position as
we know uh thanks to
benching jalen hurts in game 256 so
um maybe the jets can move down to nine
and take somebody else potentially
at the next spot and amass more draft
choices and build around that person
who they could maybe even sit behind
darnold for a year or
not even do that get donald more
protection the reason why i ask this is
who else
is out there quarterback was that you
think might be worthy
of a first-round grade that could make a
team
uh highly successful if not a champion
eventually i'm not
named wilson or lawrence chris simpson
right right yeah
you know i i think if the jets do that
you know first off
it's risky because like you said i mean
hey okay the eagles
trade up you know you got carolina
number eight they're obviously in the
quarterback conversation they'd be a
team i'd look at that might want to
trade up to
pick number two and take a guy like zach
wilson i mean they're they're secretly
kind of
set up with weapons on offense with
robbie anderson and dj moore a pretty
good tight end mccaffrey i mean
that would excite me and i'm still not
putting them out of that desean watson
trade mix there really either
but i think if they make that move there
you know where they trade down hey i
love mac jones
uh i'm the one i put my neck out there
more than any
forget zach wilson over trevor lawrence
is kellan monde
all right that's another one that number
four who i love
i look at him as a first round talent
and prospect and everything about it
but just as particular to the jets there
rich i just think if they make that type
of move
then you sit there and you keep sam
darnold you go with that
he does fit that system and now you
build around him and finally get him
some receivers and some you know
a top end running back and some more
protection on the offensive line
and you build that way but my heart of
hearts i just really think it's going to
be zach wilson at two
and then i expect them to trade sam
darnold and
you know i've been saying for weeks i i
think a sam darn of the 49ers thing
would would make a whole lot of sense to
me
in a lot of ways but you know the uh the
the other quarterbacks
mac jones was blown away by him better
prospect than two last year coming out
in the draft
no kidding yes i know yeah i i i look at
him and just go
first thing is the throwing is off the
charts
now i don't mean like his arm just goes
wow what great power
but it has plenty of power it's more
power than joe burrow had last year
coming out in the draft
and just like burrow i've never seen a
guy
who can go through reads and process
information at this college level since
i've been involved in this side of the
business
that's where i'm blown away um and you
know i know everybody talks about the
athletic stuff and
oh yeah i wish he was a little faster
but i don't watch the film and go oh my
gosh he's
he's in quicksand this guy he's a
liability he can't move
he has incredible feet in the pocket and
he can run for six
and seven when you need him to in the
nfl so he is a guy i look at that would
be
i would think would be very much in play
for carolina and number eight
and i think is certainly a top 10 top 12
draft pick in the nfl draft all right
before we let chris sims go chris
brockman can you ask him the poll
question that we're going to post up at
rich eisen show please
chris throwing this up right now which
quarterback from the 2018
draft class would you next give a
long-term contract
baker josh allen lamar none of the above
what do you got oh i'm gonna go with
josh allen you know first off i was a
huge josh allen fan coming out in the
draft
josh allen is a superstar he is in that
level of mahomes
you know look like look at the nfl we're
talking about the draft it's still about
your ability to make throws in the
pocket you look at the final four
it's brady's and rogers it's mahomes and
allen
allen is special he is in the the the
upper class of the nfl
and i think he's a no-brainer he'd be
the guy i re-up first chris thanks for
the time let's do this more often i'm
not i plan on speaking to you before
super bowl 60 likes how about in a
couple weeks how does that sound
sounds good you let me know i'm down
richard i appreciate that chris thank
you right back at you chris sims
unbuttoned is his podcast
and of course you can catch him with
florio every single day
to kick off the nbc sports on peacock
lineup on pft live
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here